[Musique]
tout-le-monde hébreu à l'aise
et avec nous n'est pas
toi comme ça en pression je te dit la
femme avait jeté pas là mais cette fois
ils tous à barcelone mais comme tabou
chômage et tu fermes ta bouche
franchement là non est en train de me
garder toit des gens debout que je
regarde mon père
je n'ai pas pensé
au bénin
nous dit
[Musique]
le 1
terminée en 2020 bamboche
là pour bolt ses filets
la bombe os c'est terminé le président
de la commission monsieur bax.n disait
qu'il n'avait aucun élément sur les
études faites sur le fameux vaccin
sister à l'école et puis on a changé les
choses et on sait ce qu'il a
lutté le vaccin moi j'ai fait le sister
dont le pisteur aussi bon ça se passe
belge est debout
je peux même pas venir vous faire un
câlin avec le pot vide oh vous savez
quoi je mets mon masque et je viens vous
faire un câlin je suis vacciné vous êtes
vacciné aussi garder on me l'étais votre
masque est dit
hollande a bar pour puisse plus faire de
câlins regarder voilà ça fait des mois
que j'ai envie de faire des câlins des
candidats
voilà
au canada la chaîne de magasins wal-mart
a décidé de retirer un jouet il s'agit
d'un cactus parlant destiné aux enfants
problème plusieurs personnes ont
remarqué quand le déclenchant il tient
des propos pas franchement adapté aux
enfants
j'ai décidé de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle estimant ça peut faire un
flipper les gosses depuis des mois nos
meetings dérange les journalistes agace
mais politique et hystérise la gauche
je suis différent des autres oui et le
présentateur il dit à zemmour eric
zemmour etes-vous raciste lui dit non
même pascal praud il a fait pardon mais
est en fait c'est par modestie il est
modeste ricco comme comment me dis que
j'ai connu maurice tlo littératie feno
c'est gentil mais elle a de meilleur
voici la vraie version la vraie version
qui pose problème quand on active le
jouer c'est ce titre polonais qu'il
chante
[Musique]
tu t'excites qui m'excite
l'alcool la drogue
[Applaudissements]
je dis bien jamais pris ça de ma vie
techcite baisse j'ai pensé à des trucs
mais c'est ça c'est ça qui nous inquiète
mireille dumas ici présentes c'est déjà
drogué en pleine émission ouais ouais
ouais apurement une carrière aussi
longue ne peuvent bien sûr que les
choses oui bien sûr c'est vrai françois
morel bon je dirais oui oui en me
regardant bah oui dans l'aveu dit si
c'est vrai ou faux c'est vrai
tout le monde
alors bagasse et mamie sylviane il ya 98
elle marche encore très bien ils vont
encore même de l'alcool et c'est ma
mamie
[Musique]
bertrand ça c'est le tenant du titre
franciska mento ou le triple champion du
monde depuis le moche et son secret pour
gagner soigner tous les détails j'ai
voulu faire une robe avec j'ai pris les
colonnes de ma femme vous voyez quoi
avec n'importe j'arrêtais les messieurs
quand vint maps et chevelus
[Rires]
vérité mais on est obligé de tu parles
de quoi dans ce spectacle je parle de
mon parcours comment j'ai quitté
marseille pour paris des doigts voix est
exactement cet arrêt et comprendre que
chantal ladesou quai du mont palomar
la photo est belle était presque
[__]
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous voyez vous
me regardez là qu'est ce que vous voyez
vous c'est particulier ceux vus parce
que vous êtes particulièrement belle
[Rires]
parmi les probables successeurs de
francis il dit à vincent alias le beau
pull moche et coupu les
basses le combo le must tout ce qui est
un coût de 8 ou c'est trop la mode à ça
ce moment c'est une mais c'est vrai
qu'il volait pas c'est très sérieux
enfin prêt pour monter sur scène fait
aulas
vous regarder l'amour est dans le pré
non c'est votre copine qu'arrive le mari
oui mais j'ai plein d'amis qui font des
merdes et je la regarde pas
on embrasse carré
ce matin encore j'ai été connu
peut-être chez petiot adéquat
le suspense d'une longue délibération
et puis c'est l'explosion de joie
[Applaudissements]
le beauf et champion du bien sûr on peut
toujours objecter que la vérité dépasse
la fiction mais souvenons nous de ce
qu'en disait le grand écrivain québécois
hubert aquin la vérité dépasse la
fiction en cela qu'elle est infiniment
plus décevante dans un instant le
journal météo chloé n'a bézian qui nous
annonce encore de la pluie sur la
majeure partie du pays même à marseille
avec terreur laurent delahousse pour le
journal et non se quitte en musique avec
une chanson d'un mec qui s'appelle
soprano berry mont everest et n'oubliez
pas le 36 37 ou sur le site telethon.fr
pour vos promesses de dents à partir de
18h30 voilà vous avez gagné ma place